enquanto em do bb on e gostava que ele
jamais um vídeo e hoje vou ensinar como
fazer e tive de pular barquinha vapor
que como vocês acabaram de perder o
início da trilha é daqui é uma categoria
pois é agora muito vocês lado está a
contar esse vídeo historial
isso já não fizesse tutorial vez fazer
só que já fiz
só que na hora que eu fizer em falmouth
basicamente por sorte meu irmão é fazer
o projeto e com música de fundo não
falei nada
expliquei nada e aí muita gente deixando
comentários até estava muito projeto
ficou muito feliz com as coisas que a
gente tem em casa é o vídeo mais ficar
falando aqui e vai fazer um pouquinho e
tal como eu vi que era muito comentário
tende a cair vou fazer
o tutorial desta vez mais pagar é
explicar passo a passo e pronto você não
precisava fazer isso porque em 1º
juizado de uma lata de bebida energética
red bull mas pode ser produtor tomar o
marca qualquer importante é que seja com
esse formato ao lado até e bebidas
energéticas momento em uma lata em que o
dia ficar em cima é mais aqui na
comparação com as baterias convencionais
do sul e são josé muito mais altas a
equipe só agora também assume que vai
nestas matérias produção um pouco sobre
os poucos bens dessas latas as pessoas
encontrarem submersas lá só podem
comprar tanta que ela tem esse aspecto
ela tem que fazer com que a galera vai
precisar de uma embalagem trabalho ou
seja uma embalagem de insumo para fazer
e que a estrutura do barco quando este
material é resistente à água e pra vocês
podem porém por várias vezes que não vai
estragar
além disso os dados de precisar de duas
planilhas de suporte é porque dentro da
caldeira é manter porque a água vai
entrar
a lei sítio é fazer caldeira eu
precisava uma cola especial do qual
época em que pronto nem vou falar muito
caro em portugal estão o euro
o brasil não sei quanto custa manter
calmo marca veja aqui pronto é marcará o
dita hipótese foi em 2000 na garagem
conselho misturam de usar bastante foi o
que por duas bisnagas mistura antes de
aplicar aqui e pronto pois os argumentos
de todos que entraram na casa e prólogo
latas ou seja quero essa cola é muito
resistente a altas temperaturas e vão
usar porque cabe a ele por enquanto
continua a enriquecer tem que agüentar
temperaturas anéis vão precisar de uma
cola desta aquilo era uma pistola de
cola quente aqui um pouquinho aí pronto
claro que é caldeira a estrutura do
barco é isso ai é um batom for precisa
de fogo e gostar também de uma velinha
vai se estender para criar aqui
temperatura e fazer por dentro da
caverna
plantei software o turquia passa passa
embora ó pessoal vamos lá começar a
fazer espetacular projeto primeiro com
vários exato e fazer um corta numa das
extremidades da lata o suficiente para
caber a vossa tesoura tesoura e cortem
até o fim
corta a outra extremidade também vamos
para o mar o que tiverem com cuidado
para não cortar em vossas mãos de vocês
usarem luvas ou usar a fazer trabalhos
manuais e tenho a pele bastante
resistente grossa a cair depois vocês
vão atrás da lata
é importante vocês façam isso para não
atrapalhar depois agora vão traçar uma
linha na perpendicular na extremidade da
cae marcar a volta 10 11 ou do centro
outra linha pretende colar site
acontecer duas linhas em paralelo
feito isso vou marcar o maio
neste caso é 45 entro e provar o nosso
caso também seja depois é só testar uma
linha para juntar os dois pontos nesta
linha servirá só para orientação e agora
é só cortar este quanto cheste
agora vamos dobrar na direção da linha
do mai tem que ficar muito sobre o posto
a linha o dedo e vincar bem colocado
para fazer o mesmo para outro lado o
efeito bonito coloca a red bull fica
xadrez
brincar é importante encarar sempre
marcar 0,51 para dentro mas atenção tem
que ser da linha branca vinho toda a
parte pois através do início do brasil
mais um bocadinho até ficar pronto
completamente cobrado em dobro tudo uma
vez não vai partilhar as vossas duas
bolinhas que aproveitar a data inicial e
vou preparar a minha cola epóxi
mostrando os dois componentes mais fácil
daqui em cada introduzir a linha por
linha tem duas partes uma grande e outra
pequena parte pequena por cola no meio
desse segmento bastante cola e agora só
entrou dizer pra dentro do poço tal têm
que introduzir a outra linha também
agora por cola e os orifícios laterais
é importante porém bastante cola para
que depois nós o vazamento de ar
feito isso
e como vocês estão vendo vídeo maneira
que as pernas fiquem no centro
agora é só por cola em todas as partes
que poderá haver fuga de ar ok agora
pega negócio embalagem tetrapak que
corta em um retângulo da frente ou traz
hoje é só dobrar ou maio
é claro que encara este material é muito
bom fazer barco é porque é um material
bastante resistente à água uma vez que
pronto na assembléia essas embalagens
fica sul
agora vamos cobrar desta maneira para a
linha do centro
vim cá outra vez é importante encarar
sempre pronto para fazer o mesmo com
outro lado do bar triângulo retângulo
depois dobrar a tesoura e cortá los
agora façam esse triângulo aqui em todos
os todas as partes e claro vincar sempre
brincar
agora vamos dar a nossa cola convém que
seja é uma cola como esta nunca use é a
cola époxi porque ela demora muito tempo
a buscar fazer isto é em todas as partes
e aqui temos que virar o barco ao
contrário uma vez que a parte da
assistência ao fogo está na parte
exterior vão virar o barco de volta à
escola não vai funcionar em um carro
o cabelo lá as duas bolinhas
agora uns por cola para que não há água
no inter para dentro do barco
agora muita atenção mas não criar parte
que está lisa do do motor fica virada
para baixo que está inclinada para baixo
na direção das bolinhas é muito
importante estância desta maneira caso
não esteja é o barco vai andar mais
devagar
estou por lá cola por baixo também não
entrar água e agora vou aprender as
bolinhas
estou bastante cola para que haja uma
pequena distância entre o barco e as
panes assim vai estar o oferecimento
mais rápido e agora está na hora de
enfeitar agosto eu vou porque uma cabine
que eu fiz usando os restos de
embalagens tetrapak do outro lado
agora uma coisa que fica muito bem vocês
porém o suporte para a vela escolar em
velas
ela é pra vocês vão ter que mudar mas
quando elas acabaram então vai ser uma
grande chatice
agora vocês fizerem suporte será mais
fácil por retirar as velas suporte para
baixo do doutor agora só por lá a
velinha
nunca deixe queimar até o final sua mãe
depois terem outra
[Aplausos]
bem só espero que nenhum estado tem
conseguido fazer se for o caso dos autos
estarão mesmo mesmo mesmo da chuva só eu
posso favorito
inscreva-se no canal se ainda não for
speed província ajuda pra caramba quem
está escalado e jo no meu primeiro que
eu devo continuar trazendo para o canal
se tiver alguma sugestão é deixar os
comentários que costuma atender a um
desses pedidos
você tiver alguma dúvida sobre o que
vocês viram
é para deixar os comentários de que eu
vou responder mas atenção só vou
responder é dúvidas a cair porque não
for dúvidas eu não vou responder por
peço desculpas ao início respondíamos
aguardando a posição demasiado os
comentários o leitor de manhã achei
responder agora já não consigo ficar em
um hospital você sabia que você é e só
desejo que vocês podem ver que está a e
pronto
terminada a espécie é necessário até a
próxima